hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hallway potatoes a weapon
shop now this game was just released on
Steam as well as rocket League but I saw
this one because apparently it's like a
commerce game where you have a weapon
shop and you're trying to give weapons
to everyone in the world who also
happens to be a potato see you're arming
potatoes present nevermind here we go
hmm where is that silly spud I said to
meet me here in de morning he's really
not like his grandfather in any way
going by that letter he sent back well
he might be a potato so he might not be
able to write da mister agent of course
I'll come
what's good to eat in that part of the
town silly empty-headed fool yeah the
joke is not lost on me that he's agents
46 of course it's all the better for me
to imagine that you owe your here's last
sorry I got lost
alright I've been waiting all morning
stand back for my welcome spiel that's
what all potatoes is fire - apparently
I'm - what that's not your voice I just
established your voice let's earn lots
of starch ow he knows I can't facepalm
myself with my microphone it just
doesn't work hah yeah yeah yeah look
break my nose oh wow pound starch is all
over made of cuz we're potatoes what are
you yes but it's also our currency you
do know what starch is don't you no not
at all huh Sarge
yeah I'm not very good with this
Baba's been giving me pocket buddy for
years right well don't worry I'm great
with it I'll help you with complicated
finance stuff and expand our business
worldwide together I'm sure we can make
lots of starch yeah
the how I don't know a big idiot
well for starters you're going to need
to forge powerful weapons to do that for
us I'll teach you how by okay-y huh but
first do you have anything easier than
patata Lada kartoffel PR dapple Papa
that I can call you oh you need the
combine markiplier with potatoes
markiplier with potatoes
markiplier with the tod but now it's
done wait that's not my shop spud but
spud bunch fudge fun fun good fun much
fun smart about fun Gibson fun fun get
fun fun
welcome to the weapon shop here's 500
starts to get you started
oh good you're new in town so you're an
idiot
great I don't know anything and
obviously I need lots of help top right
panel shows date and time top left shows
a bunch of [ __ ] that's whoa who the
hell is that oh I'm not gonna be all
good cuz I'm an idiot I wouldn't know
what to do hi Laura
why does the potato have boobs why she's
good at adding attack weapons great why
okay Smiths can attack at attack speed
accuracy and magic stats still weapons
Oh
Oh Oh I'm okay Oh I'm a shop I mean now
that was obvious that's not the big
revelation I'm having I'm a shop in an
RPG world that the heroes come and buy
their weapons I'm the guy and I'm a
potato okay all right thank you
Oh God bulk bogan russet Peters wow
they're better at names anion for -
dagger I don't know if I'm ready for
that
what is the Skyrim okay thief would
prepare that all right start yeah this
is how we make weapons Hey Oh we're done
we're done now oh no we're back in the
party I don't know what the hell's
happening wow they're going super season
that random moments what the hell is
happening
Hey what'll I name the weapon the blood
stabber
the official what stabber is the first
weapon of this horrible horrible weapon
shop named after the sound people make
after getting stabbed with it the pots
the birds actually what people would say
kitten see I'm trying to get all my
horrible jokes out of the way first so I
can get to the mediocre ones cuz god I
need to get to the mediocre ones I can't
believe it
by fist weapon first sorry not fisting
don't go all start oh don't go all star
you died on me spud but we're not done
yet there tons of ears around the world
who need weapons now that you've made a
weapon you need to sell it to them
I feel so happy so happy I feel like
singing ah subtle hello sorry let's get
down to business to forge some weapons
I'm assuming those Mulan
be quiet I'm not done yet selling
weapons to heroes let them fight more
monsters which in turn lets them earn
exp in level up the more your weapons
benefit a hero the more Fame you'll
receive so how do I know if a weapon
benefits a hero I can't follow out into
battle or can't I Oh pay attention
there's no adventuring here you're a
blacksmith I'm the blacksmith I found me
it was a long life soul-searching
journey ha oh come back now oh the
heroes will let you know if your weapon
was beneficial or not by giving it a
grade or by giving you that location of
their grave
you might have made a really awesome
staff but if you get into a rogue who
has no use for it at all you're not
going to score very well one is their
fault buyer beware
a rogue should know whether he should
need a staffer but stab her dad sounds
like school ah not really you just need
to pay attention to a hero's likes and
dislikes you got that
hell yeah I guess cheer up spot but it's
not that difficult now all about
continuing your song that should cheer
you up oh you like my singing a list a
lot more from you on what I'm
they send me flowers oh did they send me
flowers when I asked for iron Oh
anyway guess we're playing the game now
dude so hot here so hi Alma thought I
just poked myself in the eye I'm so hot
sexy ow
okay world map who wants it who wants a
nice fresh bunch dabber ah pretty good
pretty good huh okay new village
clapped-out of faith all right cool yeah
do you best look why is that guy dead
why did that guy die
Oh bogan now both bogan you okay bulky
bulky bulky okay so all the
notifications about what's going on is
gonna pop up there sniffle send you a
message I'll get a message Oh what Oh Oh
over here okay all right then yay what
obviously the thief like of course um
none I got starch which I can only
assume is the blood of my fellow potato
man and I'm horrible
great how'd you do you got it you got
exactly as much money as he was offering
great job all right oh you don't think
it was last long
well you know what else I don't think of
last long no hey I did it
I got fame oh boy oh boy okay anyway be
a man why why can't you be a woman
what's wrong with in that sexist all
right let's do some good be doing oh
hell yeah do them oh I don't have
anything I don't get materials how am I
gonna get materials let's get a speed
boost on that baby oh yeah
what Oh what's my guy ah I see you got
it that's good stuff man you go you go
buddy
you go buddy boom you're doing bulk
bogan I know you were dead a little bit
ago but good for you all right well I
mean you haven't done much else work so
I don't know who all right one oh well I
named this one Jabbar Kirk Jabbar Herc
because you're talking about the
Jabberwocky and then you get stabbed in
the dog come on - Jabar work who wants
it it's got it's very speedy very speedy
whoa sell BAM
who wants something yeah yeah I know
y'all do I didn't select the weapon go
buy okay what now how do I get materials
clap dog head you're gonna level up
pretty good yeah you want 640
ha damn ha ha damn way oh yeah by my
jabber hope you didn't sweep you didn't
sweet it up you didn't Wheaton the deal
at all
BAM whoopee frickin oh I can buy stuff
now where can i buy stuff where who do
what who did what now what huh I don't
know what's going on where can i buy
sell where yes that I want that how do
we do that all this give me stuff yeah
oh that looks tasty buy some of that
I'll get some of that we'll definitely
get some of that that's a lot of money I
can afford it
yeah I can afford it I don't know I
don't want magic dust hey go get some
stuff I don't mean to keep sending you
on errands but it's just leaves
convenient you're back yes ok it was
quite a fort whoo good job mercantile
level up nicely gun I like your candor I
forget your name but I like you this is
one of those games that I would get
stupidly addicted to for no reason at
all oh oh oh the bow of blams nah the
bow of blam does anyone want to buy my
blow both but both blam Joe it was all
your marketing skills she's the first
one in my shop so she's the best all you
stand around or some range or 62 it's
like nothing I was better off with the
dagger what a little potato boy comes up
and ask you for love advice why I'm a
blacksmith what a spell Ian must one and
we must run free love as you would want
to be loved yeah
oh okay good well the right choice
totally I'm the love guru mark EMU yeah
scrap it was a crap weapon I know
alright get art get Archer to level six
but he was wasn't he like level ten what
oh maybe it's cuz I boosted the dagger
oh I forgot outta boosting speed thank
you come on back you're the only one
that we can work with alright so we need
to we need to do another one of these oh
he was a ranger not an archer oh okay I
was confused sorry
okay we need accuracy boost yeah yeah
that's the stuff get on that yeah Oh
polish that sword oh he's so good at
polishing whatever your name is
no no what it is I wasn't paying
attention go go go go go go go go go go
go go twing my thing cuz both you twenty
nevermind who wants my twang my thang
now we think it is it's something
different
550 I should have known wasn't even
looking then I didn't rent
I thought Ranger was that never Archer
great whatever oh yeah oh yeah
you know the best black live is them not
me I don't know a damn thing about this
get two euros - max max level isn't that
a little like asking for a lot
throw that attack grow it hard oh if I
wanted to make this like super good for
some reason Donald macaroon old is
really good at that
beagle Brown Steve ma okay I'm gonna go
all out on this one I'm gonna go all out
and see what it does go yeah oh oh oh oh
my god you attacked me 69 hope to have
enough money for this one struck by
lightning whoa oh oh oh I will so boost
that again yes I should get struck by
lightning more often this is gonna be
the greatest action ever made this got
it this needs an epic name unlike any
other so epic I was gonna put macaron
olds Bane but apparently macaron olds
deal have to do anybody uh you are
molded in your hand
you sure do game you sure do hold
macaron 'old z'd in your hand
whoa whoo oh man it's it's fast and it
attacks hard area then that over time
that will look listen oh oh cool
well it means I can sell for more right
all right that's not as much as I was
hoping for
yeah I guess I put a lot love into that
macaroon put a lotta lovin macaroons D
oh I should watch what I say yay
you better lay is like the best weapon
ever I know it's great I'm amazing
oh this is actually really fun oh no not
this oh no someone left a TV set at the
door there's a remote switch it on Oh
putting all of it into this one Steve
flounder that song better go tinder good
work get a lot of speed apparently Wow
hot damn holy hell yeah you were that's
wow wow oh come on
clown flounder need or who has the
flounder near yeah it got damaged little
I mean lightning struck my last one and
it got good fired apparently no good on
forging a weapon for some reason or
another
alright woah you're paying more you owe
cuz it's so fast oh haha yeah okay I
like that I like that it's fast it was
very fast I'm gonna build the world's
greatest deck and it's gonna go so fast
oh this guy was good at speed so if I
speed up this one not as good of those
up that's better more like that
yes exactly make the thong work for you
oh come on you did okay I paint you a
lot of money for that the thong steered
me wrong apparently
not my song
that's not my [ __ ] who'd pull out of tag
you can sing these aren't my glasses
this isn't my song who wants it dammit I
made a dagger I already oh crap I'm out
of money
yay wait what's max level for that guy
okay how this one goes a little better
than last and hopefully I can get that
guy to oh ah the booger the booger
remover if you're really brave use this
one to take care of those pesky boogers
you know how it is maybe you don't cuz
you're not weird like me yes okay max
level I did it he loved the booger
remover alright did it yeah good morning
how is how is black nothing but oddly
fun wait there's no one here where is
that silly spud look under the desk look
behind the stove good morning agent 46
ah there you are how's blacksmithing
it's great I love it it sauce on
everything I love hard
everything is cool when you're part of a
team
hey that's copyrighted everything is
I'll stop singing
I'll cow cows are you I buy say is what
we base off our wow so many weapons yeah
they're so easy to bake I have really
high hopes for you spud but you truly
are botanas grandson you might not act
like whatever but he definitely for just
like batata and by that I mean he hires
other people to do the work for him
Hazen are you okay ah but it will be
your weapons are really good they remind
me of patatas when he was first starting
out how long did you know my grandpa for
a jet Oh for ages and ages
very good blacksmith and it looks like
you really take after him I never bet
him you know I wish I had he sounds like
you're really cool potato yeah this is a
pity I never got a sense
Padma foliat come by earlier what do you
mean fake come by earlier discussing
gonna run by hell honest I really good
at blacksmith grandpa
hey okay so that's all I'm gonna play
for now hey I did another thing okay
stop
what are you doing to stop whatever it
is please dear God stop all right so
that's all for whatever the hell this
game was named I don't even remember
this point but it was a lot of fun oddly
I have much more fun than I thought I
would
this is one of those games you could
easily get addicted to so let me know
what you think in the comments below
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
oh and shooting pieces of myself where
am I going oh I broke it I broke it I
broke it I broke everything why did I
break everything